hello everyone
and welcome to rational science
today we have a great day in physics
and i'm going to start with by tying
some loose ends which
you know i left the other day
in the extinction talk and
i want to fill in some gaps in there
okay and so
let me start with that before i get into
the subject of today which is
what is a circle okay okay so let's
start with this
and uh here you see some rotting
food that fruits okay you see some
strawberries at the top and some
apples and whatever on the bottom and
the first question i've got
uh is why doesn't that continue forever
you can see that there's an exponential
growth
of bacteria of fungi of
even of viruses like we have this covid
virus now
going around for those who believe in
the virus okay
um you know again it's not a question
believe it's a question of understanding
what a virus is like i said the other
day
um we don't believe
in viruses we listen to the theory
and we understand it once we understand
it that's where
science ends what continues is religion
whether you believe in it or not
okay that so that's a separate issue and
here's something similar here you have
some
uh something going on with that okay you
gotta explain
that phenomenon right there or those
phenomena okay and you say what's going
on
okay and the main thing i want to focus
here
is you can see how fast it grows at
first
and it kind of settles down okay
and so let me show you the graph for
this the graph looks something like this
okay you can see it's growing and it
goes asymptotically because at some
point it levels off
and so the question the million dollar
question for you is
why does it level off in fact uh this is
known as the
s curve and it's applicable to almost
anything involving populations that you
always use this sine wave
and let me complete that okay here it is
okay that's what it looks like really
you know it starts growing and at some
point it levels off
asymptotically you know approaches the
asymptote
and then we have this crash
that's what a population looks like
that's what would happen to those
bacteria on the strawberries or on the
um
around the fruits because at some point
they run out of food to eat they run out
of their
carrying capacity as it's known okay
and here you have a famous case uh some
of you are familiar with it
uh people who have followed me for some
time these are calhoun's mice
okay he ran his uh many experiments
about 25 at least of them with uh first
with rats done with mice
put him in a small enclosure and he let
him reproduce like
crazy as rats and mice do and at some
point they leveled off
over there you can see i think they
reached somewhere around 2000 and then
the population crashed okay and
we don't see much of that last uh part
of
the curve people don't always show that
they always show the
s curve like you know it continues
forever like leaving it
up to you to imagine what happens next
what happens next there are only three
possibilities either
it continues growing it levels off and
more or less goes you know
[Music]
steady constant for the next billion
years
or it crashes and our experience at
least
if you look at the extinctions in the
past every
species crashes every species crashes
are we an exception humans are we an
exception to
crashing okay that's the question okay
here's our
uh population over the years okay
and um question is
are we more or less like that are we
also expanding it to a point and then at
some point level off and then crash
here it's from the start you can see it
okay this is from the
year one and you see how it grows
relatively slowly at first
and you'll see towards the end how fast
it grows
the population how we expanded in the
last
200 300 years there it goes
speeds up okay and you can see how that
goes
okay that's uh
how human population has grown on the
planet if
if we look at you know the time lapse uh
picture timewise of human population
across the planet global okay and
here you have
our world population growth
now the red stuff that's our population
that's our total population
but i want you to focus really on the
green line there
because that shows our uh annual growth
rate okay that's the rate you can see
how the rate grew
together with the population but in 1963
we reached our zenith and since then
we've been coming
steadily down and i'm going to emphasize
the word
steadily because in the 14th century we
had the um
mid-14th century we had the bubonic
plague
that wiped out they say anywhere from a
third to a
half of europe of the population of
europe
and we recovered we were still quite
young you know
the population pyramid of humans was
uh quite healthy still so we could we
had a lot of young people
very few old people so we continued to
procreate
even after the 1400s but now you see
something different
now you see that in the year 1963 was
the last year where we had a very high
rate and
we've been essentially plummeting
as far as the rate is concerned you can
see how our
rate has come down and that's the reason
for
the concave curve
for the total population the red okay
that's why it's
leveling off that's why it's curving
it's approaching the asymptote
okay so that's the population pyramid
for
the the not the population pyramid but
the
total population for the earth let me
show you the uh population
pyramid okay
that's what it looks like for the world
you see it on the top
and you see different uh years here
just snapshots okay and the winning gray
in the center
that was the oldest one uh 1950
then you can see the darker gray the
blue
and the outline in red which is what is
projected for the next few years
and i'm not looking at total population
here i'm looking at
the ages remember what what's on the
y-axis there are ages
ages of people and we're seeing that um
we're seeing more people up in the
higher levels
people reaching their 60s 70s and 80s
and fewer coming from the bottom
why again because we're reproducing
fewer children
and down at the bottom you see just the
case example of the united states
also what's happened in the last few
years and what's going to happen in the
future what's projected to happen in the
next few years
here's the same pyramid shown for
for china and europe okay so you can put
it all in perspective
okay you can see what china was in 1915
what their population pyramid is turning
into what it's going to become if
everything goes according to plan by the
year 2050
and the same for europe you see what it
looked like uh
in 1950 what it's going to look like in
2015.
assuming we reached that far and you can
see uh it's getting thinner at the
bottom and
bigger at the top population pyramid is
overturning for really
the entire planet so we're going from
this to this
okay and why is that so well
i'm going to get to it because i'm going
to be answering some questions at the
end of uh
the lecture okay people who ask
questions along those lines so i'll
answer those if you stick around you'll
hear at the end of the
show okay um
let me show you this give me a second
here and get it up there
okay this we have to superimpose upon
that and that's that we're losing our
genetic diversity on top of all this
okay and i say that the reason for this
is that
for the last 200 300 000 years we've
been
inbreeding we've been having sex with
each other and not with any other
uh animal or cousin
that can enrich our gene pool okay so
uh with we've been in breeding 200 000
years of inbreeding and more
okay and now even a pack of chimpanzees
uh maybe a troop anywhere between 50 and
100 chimps
has more genetic diversity than
the entire human race
that makes you kind of think you know
we've lost our genetic diversity anyone
who you marry today is essentially your
brother or your sister
genetically okay from a genetic
standpoint
and so we end up with this okay
and these are the uh what tells you
when a species is old according to bill
gate
okay so uh you don't believe me
gate you'll you'll be okay okay but this
is what i propose is
what um
mother nature gives clues to what an old
species
looks like those are the symptoms of an
old species
reproduction low fertility which is what
we have today we have very few kids
we're having fewer kids as time goes by
we live long lives
when you live long you've lived that
means you've been around for too long
okay and you might say well we've only
been 200 000 years on the earth
and the dinosaurs were here millions of
years
yes first of all you got to look at
mammals that's one issue but the other
issue is that
not everybody follows the same cur in
other words we follow all the same shape
of the curve but not all curves
are so lengthy some are very flattened
out like it happens very quickly
okay and you know that s curve that i
just showed you
happens quite quickly and for us it
happened quite quickly why because we
managed to
um conquer the planet
we came in across all kinds of diseases
we got used to those diseases
uh which became endemic you know we get
the
colds every year they don't kill us
anymore they used to
wipe out humanity they don't do that
anymore smallpox has been eradicated
and it was killing fewer and fewer
people as time went by even without
vaccines because we started getting used
to them
remember we used to cough at the aztecs
they would
die like flies why because the spaniards
had some exposure to the to this disease
for
thousands of years which was in the uh
eurasia region america's never
had come across that and when we came
when spaniards came over you know they
just coughed and
the aztecs fell why the uh spaniards
could
you know they were used to these
diseases
and so now you know we've covered the
planet we've found almost every disease
there is out there that could affect us
and you know if there's a disease out
there that can kill us
we're gonna kill it before it kills us
that's one issue the other one is that
we're probably gonna
uh get used to it it becomes endemic
okay so that's
all that happens to diseases in the long
run
okay and um we're big
we have big sizes for a mammal
even for a mammal you know not as many
mammals are as big as us
uh we're numerous we're almost eight
billion
big mammals on the planet and again
we've
lost our genetic diversity we've got
very low genetic diversity
these are the symptoms of a
species that is about to reach its end
that's on the last leg
according to me okay so food for thought
and i just wanted to fill those holes in
there
okay um also before i get to circles i
want to
talk about an article i read today
it's about a gentleman his name is carlo
rovelli
he's a mathematical physicist so-called
physicist
okay we call them here mathematicians
they do everything by magic
all their physical interpretations are
not even magic
they're unimaginable magic was what they
had
in uh in the days of traditional
religions you know when they
brought in uh angels and god and uh
and uh spirits and they used to do all
this
magical work out there no no uh
quantum mechanics as we saw the other
days um
is no longer even magic it's irrational
you cannot even imagine it and that's
what these people
uh preach they all believe in this all
these mathematical so-called
physicists believe in these mathematical
explanations and why do i mention him
well let me
point out who he is first uh it's this
gentleman here okay
uh he's an italian math magician
and he wrote an article a couple days
ago and i just found
it today in a
magazine called new scientist it says
quant
the title was quantum weirdness isn't
weird
if we accept that objects don't exist
[Laughter]
so uh you have to if you once you can
see
that objects don't exist you're okay
then then you're fine
that's what robel is saying now this guy
is a phd okay he's got many years
you know not only teaching but uh
mathematical physics but uh he also does
experiments he worked at cern
in fact he's going to give a talk
concern at cern i think
sometime in april and this is a summary
essentially is
his channel saying he says we can grasp
the truth
about the quantum world as long as we
abandon
our most cherished assumption about
what's real
and what's not and uh
the only comment i'm gonna make here is
that he doesn't define what real is he
doesn't define
the word exist because no one has in the
last 10
000 years so physics is the science of
existence
physics studies that which exists but
there's no
so called physicist really mathematical
physicist
that has ever defined the word exist and
the reason is very or the word for that
matter the word object the word thing
you know you can't do physics without a
thing imagine there's nothing in the
universe
absolutely nothing god comes in there
wipes out everything
what is there to study what is happening
what are you seeing
what are you what can you do experiments
with and so on
okay there's nothing there now you must
have something
in order to do physics and it better be
something that exists
so physics is not only the science of
existence but the word existence
embodies
objects only objects can be said to
exist
for the purposes of physics okay and he
hasn't learned this
this fellow he studied 10 years at the
university and
went into professionalism and he doesn't
know these basic things and so he
doesn't define the word real
that's going to be 90 of the problem he
doesn't define the word object
we don't know what an object is
according to him okay no one has
ever in mathematical physics and there's
a reason for that by the way you know
uh you know just grab any you don't have
to take my word for it you grab
any textbook of physics right
any textbook of physics your choice okay
i don't care which one you grab
okay high school college uh kindergarten
library uh scientific journal whatever
you will never find the word uh any of
these books that begins by defining what
an object is
and you would think that's the first
word that a physicist
a genuine physicist has to define the
word object because you can't do physics
without objects so you would have to say
this is what an object is okay
what all these people do is they work
with the informal see touch
criteria criteria
they think that an object is that which
you can see or touch
which is the notion of ordinary speech
not of science
and these people work with that informal
definition they bring it into science
casually as a matter of fact and that's
the one they're going to use they're
going to use the seed touch
and as we found out the other day
because you introduce c
touch you confuse object with exist
they think those two words are synonyms
that an object is that which exists why
because you can see and touch it
and what exists is what you can see in
touch so object that exists
are synonyms that's the logic they have
in the back of their minds
and of course all of that is nonsense
total nonsense
irrationality an object is not that
which you can touch or see
an object is that which has shape and
existence is an object that has
location okay so we have a difference in
definitions and that's going to make
the whole the whole uh difference here
between what this gentleman is saying
and what i'm going to
criticize him now about okay so what
does he say
well here here he says the following
he says uh there's those are the
definitions i said you have them there
also i defined the word concept okay
word that invokes two objects that's a
short version
i'm not going to get into that it's just
going to become impertinent here
he says here's a chair in front of me
this is how he starts his article
a nice red wooden chair with four legs a
seat to sit on
a rest to support the sitter's back does
this chair exist by itself
we don't know what exists means but
let's continue let's find out of course
it does
it exists regardless of me great we're
done
finished sephie knee dot period
but he says but wait we call it a chair
because what
we touch it he says because we sit on it
see he thinks that a chair is an object
because you're gonna touch it you're
gonna interface with it you're gonna sit
on it you're gonna do something with it
otherwise he says it's not a chair
okay he's not it's not an object unless
you touch it that's what he's getting to
that's what he's got in the back of his
mind that's what he's introducing here
very slyly without even knowing
unwittingly
and he says the following he said would
there be the concept of a chair
concept of a chair i thought a chair was
an object
what do you mean a concept concept is
what he works with
energy mass time those things that he
bends and he moves around that he
transfers
those are concepts chair if i transfer a
chair i'm transferring an
object so so he thinks it's a concept
that
it's important to highlight these things
so that you can follow along
read between the lines what this guy is
saying okay
uh without its relation to us without
sitting humankind
again he's talking about see touch
that's his notion of what an object is
because he's a mathematician what can he
know about
science okay maybe not but even if
someone were unaware of a chair's
intended function
okay its components would still exist
what do we mean by exists well we don't
know because he never defined the term
of course he would never be able to he's
a mathematician how can he define the
word
exists he doesn't deal with objects
every day he deals with equations with
numbers
so he's the wrong person to be
interpreting
what's going on in the world and in the
microscopic world
and in the macroscopic world out there
you know relativity
these people have no uh mental capacity
uh to deal with these issues they're not
trained not skilled for these things
everybody thinks they're geniuses
because they can read the hieroglyphics
of math and they say oh look he knows
how to read all those equations he must
be a genius
well he might be a genius for that
language which is all that it is it's
like saying that a chinese
is uh intelligent or genius because he
knows
chinese and this is more or less the
same thing you know he knows
math which is a language and because he
knows this language of relations
everybody thinks he's a genius
and it turns out that because of that
you put your faith in him that he can
interpret the world for you
just like the priests of lol used to
interpret
the uh the bible for the flocks who did
not know how to read
in the middle ages he was the only guy
who could read in town so you know
he's a genius that's more or less the
situation today
maybe not but even if someone were
unaware of a chair's intended function
again he's
focusing on function okay its components
would still exist
for instance the smooth red wood it is
made of made of
meteorology religion an elephant
is not what it is made of it's not the
atoms that comprise it
an elephant is what i'm pointing to
that's an elephant
that's a chair that's a table that's a
tree that's a rock
a rock is not the atoms it's made up
iraq is not gazillion atoms and it often
is two gazillion atoms
that's not what a an elephant or a rock
is a rock is what i'm pointing to but
this guy introduces muriology again
all the uh irrational notions that these
people
have been brainwashed with okay over
years
and what they just repeat casually
because they're not even aware
of their uh you know what they're doing
or what they're saying okay
what does red mean who cares you know
well but
in this context it refers to an
interaction between the wood
light scattering off fit and particular
receptors in our eyes okay so
he could have saved all that he just
says it's the wavelength
okay wavelength of frequency link length
under the
rope model um
number of links okay
okay but uh he continues it's important
to see
where this guy is headed with all this
he says the following
okay goes in here he says regardless of
that the atoms of the wood
are there okay the atoms are there so
what even in the absence of our
receptors or the light that may bounce
off those
atoms okay dig down deep enough and
things
things remember he's talking about
things okay
i don't know what he knows but what a
thing is but he says these are things
have properties that are independent of
anything
else right well shape for example that's
the only property all
things have it's the only property that
is universal
okay but i don't guess he doesn't know
what shape is perhaps not
quantum physics they call it physics
which describes the bizarre behavior of
the physical world at the most
elementary level we know maybe telling
us the opposite
things don't have properties exclusive
to themselves
their properties only exist properties
exist
i thought it was objects that can exist
what do you mean properties
exist there is no such thing in science
as a concept
existing property is a concept concepts
don't exist
okay not in science maybe in religion so
he's talking about religion this fellow
and he says their properties only exist
by virtue of their relationship to other
things in other words he's talking about
again see
touch just like there are no really
there
are really no chairs without someone
around to interact
with them and see them as such again
interaction what is he talking about
what you can see or touch you talking
about interaction that's what quantum
deals with
okay you want to see touch they want to
do experiments
okay that's that's what the quantum is
about
coming to terms with this idea may
clarify the persistently mysterious
nature of the quantum world
no no the reason uh
quantum has an irrational explanation
has nothing to do with coming
in you know in contact or interacting or
anything like that
it's got to do with the fact that
quantum relies on particles
it's the particle hypothesis which is
irrational
which cannot be used to explain one not
a single
uh phenomenon of the microscopic world
all of them failed with the uh quantum
with the so-called particle
model you cannot explain straightness
why light travels straight
um you cannot explain um
you know diffraction uh the wave nature
of
light you can explain any of the wave uh
um characteristics of light or
attributes of light
with a particle i mean does the particle
move up and down
does one little particle follow the
other one when they do the little sine
wave thingy
why would the particle move up and down
if it's a discrete particle that is not
in contact with the next particle down
the road
and so you cannot explain this or you
know you have more irrationality when
they say you know a particle can be in
two places at once
or that this particle over here you know
through entanglement can affect that
particle over there
if i went by what mechanism
please explain the mechanism and what
they do is just put spirits in there
they put magic you know they say this
one does when this one is clockwise the
other one goes
counterclockwise and vice versa oh yeah
and uh
by what mechanism and that's where they
die they cannot explain
a single phenomenon of quantum mechanics
of you know the microscopic world's
subatomic world
with particles so it's the particle
hypothesis that led
people like rovelli to believe in all
this nonsense just parroted
what he inherited in you know in school
it just it just regurgitates what he
learned that's it
he's uh an echo of you know what
people from born onwards uh invented all
this nonsense
uh here's my summary for mr rovelli
which uh essentially parrots the entire
establishment
mathematical establishment why does
carlo
uh invoke objects in existence in his
dissertation
i mean you know these people believe
that physics is about equations and
descriptions they say well the physical
interpretations that's philosophy
they send you to the other side of
campus they don't even publish that
stuff
like if you go in and try to criticize
quantum mechanics or relativity
or string theory in a one of their
magazines one of their journals
they won't print it because they say
well we know it's irrational we don't
understand it either that's the answer
you'll get
and you'll say hold it you're saying
that you know your explanation
physical interpretations are irrational
you cannot imagine
what came before the big bang you cannot
imagine a particle in two places at once
etcetera etcetera etcetera etcetera
and they say well that's philosophy so
why is he trying to do philosophy
i mean he should stick to equations if
if
physics as they see it is just equations
descriptions mathematical descriptions
running experiments doing predictions
all that stuff
hey just stick to that don't tell me
how the microscopic world works which is
what he's trying to do here he's trying
to interpret
what's going on in that secret world of
mother nature
she's he's trying to identify those
secret agents and they're always
particles or waves right one-way
particles one-way waves and he's trying
to tell you how the universe works
and you say hold it that's i thought
that was philosophy i thought you were
just going to
limit yourself your dissertation to
descriptions
you know mathematical descriptions you
know he's jumping the gun he's coming
into
physics he's trying to tell you that he
knows how that subatomic world works
and when you put him against the wall he
said well that's philosophy anyways
so why is he doing philosophy so if
physics is about
equations and describing mathematically
why does cardo attempt to give a
physical interpretation to phenomena
in other words philosophy why doesn't
carlos stick to what he calls physics in
other words equations and descriptions
what's this about objects in existence
what's that got to do with
quantum mechanics okay and the answer is
very simple
for otherwise his mathematical
descriptions are
rubbish that's what they are they're
worthless they have no
value whatsoever unless he can apply
them to
the physical world and if he's going to
give us an irrational physical
interpretation for the physical world
what is equation what is his description
worth
yeah he can describe what he saw and
what he saw was
the visible stuff the or the tangible
stuff that's what
what he can deal with he can't deal with
the intangible stuff
that's why you know these people cannot
tell you anything about gravity because
you know you can't touch gravity you
can't see the mediator of gravity
so how does it work by magic are we
going to send gravitons
in there are we going to work space what
are we going to do there
so yeah they cannot explain the
invisible world
that's the problem they cannot explain
gravity they cannot explain
magnetism they cannot explain
electricity they
have this irrational explanation and all
these beads going from atom to atom
and so you say okay show me your atom
i want to know what your atom looks like
and what do they put they put
niels bohr adam ridiculous atom
orbiting bead and the only question
there is okay tell me what keeps the
bead bound
faithful to the nucleus why does it
spontaneously fly away why does it
spontaneously
spontaneously fall to the nucleus
i mean you have a negative b positive
proton right i mean it should fall
and be attracted right and he might say
what's orbiting okay is that sorry why
does it fly out
why does it fall in what's
what's between the electron and the
proton
if he cannot answer that question and no
mathematical physicist
can do that he he can't even start his
dissertation
he's got to start there he's got to show
us a model of his atom
and if he can't show me a rational model
of his atom and certainly he cannot do
it with particles
then he cannot even start his
dissertation because we cannot follow it
we we cannot
we cannot even begin by visualizing his
atom we cannot
understand why that electron b does not
fall or fly away from the atom and
therefore he cannot explain electricity
as the flow of electron beads because he
jumped the gun he has
he's got to start at his atom not that
electricity
and for sure he cannot explain quantum
jump i mean why does the electron be
jumping
back and forth between energy levels you
know
what compels it to fall to an energy
level why does it rise you know i mean
why does it do that little dance and he
cannot explain that
okay especially when rutherford says
that between the electron
and the proton you have just empty space
so if it's empty space which in quantum
means it's filled with all kinds of
stuff right
all these things that pop in from the
void but if it's empty space
there's nothing there why doesn't the
electron beam fall to the sun
to the center of the atom to the nucleus
he cannot explain that
and if he doesn't have an atom he can't
start his presentation and his degree
his 10-year
phd degree is worthless what he studied
was religion
a lot of math and then religion which is
what he tries to explain here
physics is physical interpretations
that's what physics
is about anyone who's outside of there
is not a physicist
okay that's how simple it is you can't
give me a rational explanation
how the subatomic world works
okay means that you do not you're not a
physicist
okay all you are is maybe a
mathematician like
mr rovelli okay
okay let's get on with the subject
matter of today and that's gonna be
uh this thingy we call uh a
a circle and the reason i chose this is
you know uh
lately we had several questions or
several issues several comments
on the circle turns out no one knows
what a circle is so i had to
create a lecture just specifically to
explain to people what uh what a circle
is okay
okay so this is the uh well now let's
see
there's another hand this
this is it this is where the guy started
he said
um
last week okay he said uh
talking about me he says i held up a
disc once again calling it a circle and
this is what he's referring to i held
this up okay
let's get the brightness out of there
okay i held this up
it's more or less uh you know round
thing okay and he says this is not a
circle this is a disc
everybody if you show them this they say
it's a circle but uh
you know the mathematicians are going to
tell you that
they learned it wrong a circle is just
some kind of outline or something so we
need to find out yeah we gotta get to
the bottom of this uh where did we all
go wrong
if this is not a circle if this is gonna
be called a disc
then what the hell is a circle okay
so uh let's get on with this let's see
if uh
we can show give me a second here let me
get the circle out of there this is what
uh you'll see
is that a circle or not and he'll say no
that's a disk
okay so that's that's what the issue is
if this is a disk then what is a circle
okay that's gonna be the question today
the million dollar question okay so
let's find out
find out what a circle is we look it up
and we start by finding out what
geometry is first let's find out what
yama i mean circle belongs to geometry
hopefully
so we go to the sites here's a
internet sites that teach geometry
okay and all of them are the same so i
just pulled two at random but
these are quite popular if you look them
up up there okay so what is geometry
definition of geometry here okay
geometry is the mathematical study of
what
shapes first and foremost you need
shapes
what does the next one say what is your
geometry is a branch of mathematics
that studies what shapes et cetera et
cetera et cetera
and it says flat shapes like square
circle
remember you're saying flat shapes
like what circles it's a flat shape
usually we don't think of uh you know
when we look at a ring we don't talk
about flat
flat usually look at a surface you know
something that extends like a sheet of
paper
or a table that's what we call flat we
look at what is a plane
also extended uh surface of some kind
that's the notion we have
of uh when we apply the word flat okay
we don't usually apply it to a string
you know in a circle we don't say oh
that's flat
that circle is flat we don't say that we
usually when we talk about flat we talk
about something like this you know which
is
i use this one for the flat earthers
okay this thing
that's that's why i keep that disc
as this gentleman would say okay around
okay so geometry is the
branch of mathematics that study shapes
and he says
this this site says flat shapes like
circles right
are a part of flat geometry and are
called
2d shapes okay let's get all these words
in there
let's remember this if we can these
shapes has only have only two dimensions
the length
and the width okay they're not the only
ones who say this
uh here we have more prominent sites
that you may have heard of
okay so let's put these up there one is
the can
academy okay and they teach uh geometry
math or
all kinds of stuff on the internet okay
and so the word geometry comes from what
earth measurement geo earth uh
symmetry meter measurement okay
the word itself comes from earth
measurement how shape
what does it study how shapes and space
and things that we see
relate to each other what does the
geometry deal with
shapes uh wolf grant
wolfram which is probably the most
popular side of the most famous site
it's interesting to say they claim or
they boast to be the web's most
extensive
mathematical mathematics resource
uh so you look up what does geometry
mean what does this word
stand for what is geometry about they
see geometry is the study of
figures blah blah blah blah blah study
of figures
uh only a little tiny problem there and
that you will not find the word figure
in their entire website so we don't know
what they study because if geometry is
the study of figures and they don't
define the word figure
then what the hell is geometry and this
is what the most extensive
site math math science resource or
whatever
okay so for this if you want to find out
what a figure is
you have no choice but to go 2 000 years
ago 2
300 or so years ago and talk to mr
euclid
okay mr euclid uh he he kind of
you know he wasn't the first one in fact
he was probably the last one
uh he kind of rounded all the knowledge
that uh they had the greeks had of uh
geometry and math and all that stuff you
know greek who inherited from the
egyptians who inherited it
from the sumerians and so on right okay
so it goes back and back and back
so all this knowledge was kind of
collected by the greeks
and euclid studied in um
in athens but he later went to
alexandria in uh
in egypt okay in the ptolemaic
uh world okay after
alexander fell from grace but he studied
at the lyceum where uh
aristotle uh taught and that was his
school
okay you have to remember aristotle was
uh
alexander's tutor and philip sucking his
father
alex's father right uh hired
aristotle to teach his son and then when
uh when alex
grew up a little he sent you know they
they kind of
had this influence over athens and uh
they sent
all these uh macedonians you know
aristotle was not a greek he was a
macedonian
and to you you might say well that's
greek to me and
no no no they would know the difference
between a macedonian and a greek
and so he was a macedonian in greek
lands he was kind of like a spy there
and
you know when alexander fell from grace
when he died you know uh
good old aristotle had to get out of
there okay
but he found elise lyceum and euclid
studied at the lyceum so he collected
all this information wrote his book
elements
and among other things he defines what a
figure is
okay so let's listen to euclid let's
find out what he says
is a figure okay he defines the figure
for us
since uh wolfram doesn't okay here it is
uh he says in his definition 14
a figure is that which is contained by
any boundary or boundaries
essentially that which has shape meaning
a figure
is what i say it is and that is what an
object is an object is that which has
shape it's not that which you can see or
touch it's that which has shape
he called it boundary or boundaries now
he did a pretty good job there the
there's only one problem here and that's
the problem that no one ever paid
attention to this definition
after uh line 14 definition 14
no one ever used that definition at all
in the last
uh 2 300 years okay so that's the
definition of a figure but no one uses
it
and no one has ever used it no one
and more important than that no one ever
realized how
important that definition is okay
now i came up with uh the same
definition but
my critical contribution is knowing or
understanding how important the
definition is see not even euclid
understood what he wrote there
he didn't realize uh how important that
definition was and the reason is very
clear
he never used that definition at all in
the rest of his book
so even though he defined the figure as
that which has shape that which has
boundary
he never used the definition in his book
so he didn't realize what he wrote
so that's the other thing i criticize
him for you know
not only do i define the word as shape
but i understand
the importance of it and i do use it
okay
uh okay so what is a circle then uh does
the circle
belong to the world of figures let's
find out
here it is he defines it in the next
definition
just the one right after that 14. number
15. a
circle is a plain what figure
yeah a circle is a plain figure what is
a figure
that which has boundaries that which has
shape right but this one is a
plane figure meaning we need to know
what a plane is
and what is a plane well a plane is you
know a continuous sheet of paper
it's a continuous surface that's what a
plane is okay
and it says contained by one line such
that all the straight lines falling upon
it from one point among those lying
within the figure equal one another
okay so we got too many problems with
that definition
the first one is that between any two
lines i can fit a billion lines
okay that's the the first problem in
others i can fit more and more lines
that means that euclid is still building
his
circle even to this day he never
finished building a circle
okay so if a circle is a bunch of lines
that fall on points
and there can be lines between any two
lines
then his uh so-called circle was never
finished
okay and so and besides that's not a
plane
again that's not a figure in the sense
that it's not a continuous
object what he's describing there is
or defining there is something that you
construct
you have to construct that circle it's
never finished because you got to
construct it
it's not like you can point to a circle
to euclid's circle
you have to build it line by line and
between any two lines you got a
gazillion lines so he
you know you'll build that circle
forever uh there is
no circle that you can point to until he
finishes
his sculpture that's the problem with
euclid's circle
okay but let's continue here
here's the modern definition one
so-called geometers of today use okay
these are the
mathematical so-called physicists who
use this definition okay
it's the one you find in the wikipedia
it's not because it's in the wiki you'll
find it in every book so it's the same
thing
these people have the same notion
everybody else has so
no problem with using the wiki here okay
circle
a shape okay consisting of all
points in a plane
in a plane in a plane what is a plane
well we'll find out in a second that are
again
that are at a given distance from a
given point
the center okay so one of the issues
we're going to find out here is whether
that center point is part of the circle
okay that's one issue the other issue
okay what do you mean shape what is
shape well shape is the form
okay so what is the form form is the
shape oh great
we learned a lot shape is the form form
is a shape
okay but it's a plane well plane is a
surface
and surface is a plane oh great we
learned a lot
that's on the wikipedia you'll find the
circularity these synonyms
they think they define the term all they
had is synonyms plane is a surface
surface is a plane shape is a form form
is a
shape great we learned a lot
but what's the problem with that circle
we got a little bit of problems there
don't we
here we have a whole bunch of points
and similar to euclid's
uh series of point uh lines you can
put gazillion points between any two
points according to mathematical physics
between any two points there are
gazillions of points why because they
don't talk about points they don't they
never give you the size of a point
they're talking about locations which is
not a geometric
figure anything made of locations
is not a geometric figure geometric
figure is what i'm pointing to
that's a geometric figure but if if
uh b2 if i'm going to build it
construct it point by point first of all
it's never going to be finished
because between any two points i can fit
another one that means it's not a
continuous
circle in other words continuous
circumference it's not united all we
have is discrete points
one isolated from the next one there's
space between any two points
then they're not points they're
locations that means you're talking
about the location of an object that is
there
which which is an undefined object it's
the point that's there what's the point
the point is the location
so we have a location inside a location
that's all we're talking about location
locations of what oh we don't know
just a bunch of locations between any
two locations you can fit
gazillions of locations great we learned
quite a bit
okay so that's uh quite circular
where do we continue from here let's uh
get this one in there
here's the uh problems with uh the
notion that mathematical physics has
let's uh see if we can summarize this
these are way at the bottom so i got to
pull them up from there okay here it is
fatal problems with a mathematical
circle okay the first one is
it's still under construction okay
between any two points there's another
one
circle of points does not enclose a
surface
okay because uh it's leaking the surface
is leaking through
through between any two points that's
trying to close it because there's
always a space between there
between points okay circle of points
does not
enclose a surface especially if the
surface is not part of the circle
i mean you know if the circle is not
this if the center if this center does
not belong to the circle
we don't even have a surface there's
this is not a
then we don't have a plane
i mean is a square just the outside
is the triangle just the outside or is
the triangle the whole
surface is the is the square of the
whole surface
is a circle the whole surface
okay otherwise what kind of plane do we
have is just
lines is that is that what a plane is
just lines
just a contour line
okay and circle points is not a plane
okay circle of points is not a figure
okay
that's muriology because all you're
saying is circle is a bunch of points
that's what you define and that's known
as muriology it's irrationality it's
religion
okay that's mathematical physics not not
science
okay we don't use meteorology an
elephant is not a bunch of points
and is what i'm pointing to okay and
likewise a plane is something i can
point to like you know i can point to
this okay i can print to this
uh circle here okay i can point to that
i can't point to a bunch of points
surrounding
space each of which each of those points
which is
a location you know i'm not pointing
anything so far
so far i've got nothing in front of me
i've got a bunch of locations
in midair that's not a circle that's not
a plane that's not a figure
okay that's a movie of you building
location by location whatever's in those
locations
a location uh frame by frame
that's all you're doing okay you're
building something in a in a movie
and uh the definition is actually a
proof because you you have to run a test
you gotta
you gotta do something yeah this tells
you how to draw a circle
uh you know point by point if that's
what a circle is right
it's just telling you how to do it they
say you just put one circle
one point next to the other and they
have to beat a certain distance from the
center etc
that's a construction that's not a
circle that's not a finished figure that
you can point to again it's not a
sculpture
and it requires an experiment yeah what
you're doing is
let's find out if it's a circle let's
build it
let's do the experiment that's what
these people are saying
okay okay and uh
here's uh the other circle that they
have and this is a
even funnier okay because uh this circle
is even worse it's uh that which is the
other
definition of the circle that wikipedia
has okay by the way
and it's uh equivalently it is the curve
traced out by a point that moves
that moves in a plane so here we have
a dynamic figure it's built
you know by rolling a little point
around so that it's this is from a given
point is constant
okay so uh is that what a figure is
is that what a sculpture is uh the guy
chiseling
is that what a sculpture is or or is a
circle which you point to
see these people are constructing it
point by point and they're saying
well you can either put points next to
each other or you can just
roll a point all around and that's
we're going to call that a circle
is that a pl is that a figure is that a
geometric
figure is that a plane
or are they talking about a movie where
a little dot
moves around and so you see it in the
frame in different locations
okay so you see the problem the problem
is that
these these are not definitions of
figures these do not belong in geometry
to begin with
none of these definitions uh belong in
geometry neither euclids
nor the dynamic nor the static one that
mathematical physics has today
okay okay so let's get the summary on
this
and here it is here's my take on this
these are the questions for you
if a circle is not is not a disc which
this is a circle okay and these people
call that a disc
okay if it's if a circle is not a disney
if it's something other than what i just
showed you if it's
something else this bunch of thoughts or
whatever
uh is a circle figure okay
is this dot going around is this
location
moving around is that a circle is that
what we call this is that a figure
okay uh and remember figure is that
which has shape or as mr
euclid said it's that which has
boundaries
uh again which is the city quantum
requirement of the discipline known as
geometry remember was geometry about
shapes is a dot moving around a shape
is that what what a shape is or is it
shape what you're
pointing to more or less you know
okay is a circle a plane i mean is it
a continuous surface
for lack of a different word you know a
sheet of paper we say
is is a surface and when it lies flat on
against the table
we say that both the table and the paper
are uh
are flat that's when we use the word
flat we don't we don't put a
little string around in a circle and say
it's flat we don't usually use the word
flat in terms of
you know little string that's rolled
around we use it when we talk about a
surface a plane
like squares like triangles like circles
like this that's that's what a
plane and what a figure and what a plane
what a
what a shape is not a
little dot going around meaning a
location that goes around because again
we don't know what's in that location
okay um again a pattern sheet that's
what i'm talking about okay
uh because that you know you cut a sheet
of paper and you say that's a circle
okay does the center point belong to the
circle
if the circle is not a plane i mean if
it's just that line that
around does the center belong to the
circle
can we talk about the center of the
circle
okay and uh what's the diameter across
empty space i mean we talk about
diameter we talk about circumference you
know
again there is there a difference
between circumference and circle then
are they synonyms circumference and
circles okay
is that what a circle is just the
outline
uh and is a circle something we
construct
uh or draw right point by point
in other words is it dynamic
all these questions are for you okay so
you can answer each one
okay let's see what kind of answers uh
you give
you know for those people who say that
this is not a circle
okay yeah a circle is what you call a
disc and whatever you call a circle we
have no idea because it doesn't belong
in geometry
that's the answer to that question
corollary if a circle is a bunch of dots
it is still under construction there are
infinite dots between any two dots
and that does not belong to the
discipline known as geometry which is
what
the study first and foremost the study
of
shapes
okay we got it so uh there's homework
for everybody
anyone who wants to give it a shot
anyone who says that i'm wrong that i'm
irrational there you have your chance
you can write all you want
explain exactly what you mean if that's
not if a disc is not a circle
okay let's get on to the questions and
comments uh for today
here's the first one fellow says
i wouldn't be surprised if we were
talking about extinction the first
few issues i wouldn't be surprised if we
see a bright future for
what safety pleasure and religion
[Laughter]
uh and he goes into a long list of
things he ranted on
infrastructure technology science r d
environmental services tourism
archaeology climate and existential risk
management
blah blah blah blah blah blah that's
what we have today
so what's new so he's saying that we
have a bright future in the same things
we're doing today that's all he said
there
and i don't know about that uh you know
again um
yeah we can all come up with the same
things we have today the issue is trying
to try to come up with something new
that we don't have today in the services
okay
not something that we already have
because uh like i said uh the issue here
is that
we've moved from labor intensive
services
to services which are all internet
services we're all internet workers okay
everybody's getting into the internet
world and just doing internet services
and that's leaving aside you know it's a
new branch of services the information
branch and all the other services the
labor intensive like you know barbering
cutting your lawn um
delivery uh
for example pizza delivery and so on uh
all those require people
okay require that you do something with
your hands
okay uh when you're doing computer
programming yeah you're using your
fingers
that's about it as much as you use your
hand but you're not doing that like on
someone else like
you're not cutting his hair you're not
cutting as long in that sense
okay it's a different type of service
it's called information you're moving
information around you're investing in
bitcoin you're
investing in the stock market uh you're
putting yourself
you're opening a branch on the youtube
or whatever
and talking about something so they put
ads in your
site and you get paid for those ads and
it's just an
ad world a commercial world to sell
things okay and that's a different kind
of world than
saying i'm going to do some barbering
for you i'm going to cut your hair
those are two different kinds of things
of
services and so yeah you got to come up
with a new types of services those
services this fellow mentioned they're
all they're what we have today they're
old services
yeah we've had them for quite a while
and i don't know if he's aware of them
and uh so here he i think he is same
fellow he can say he who already
we who already live in cities feel the
increased population
density more due to three factors
general population growth urbanization
you mentioned another one okay
urbanization which frees more land for
agriculture and nature
which lets flora and fauna recover
however we let it and itself give rise
to growth of
acceptance acceptance and interest in
hunting
my god this guy i don't know if he's
living on the same planet as i am
we must be in different worlds yeah
urbanization
uh so well let's get on that's the
answer one of the
questions i want to answer but another
thought raised the same issue or similar
issues so let's
kill those two birds with one stone
here's the other fella
he uh says the following he says in a
wealthy
nation people have less children because
they do not need children as a
retirement
okay in poor nations people have more
children for retirement
increased household wealth lowers
population and increased poverty
increases children how mistaken all
these people
are i don't know they just memorize
whatever was taught to them
they never did a minimum of research
or thinking for that matter because i
mean if israel would at least done
a minimum of thinking he probably would
have not said this he would not
embarrass himself
publicly by saying this but this is what
most people believe out there
that's what they've been taught this is
what they repeat and this is just a
parroted
okay let's find out what's wrong with
this okay and
first we uh show that he just parrots
what he reads out there or what what
is you could say the worldly wisdom okay
and this is the worldly wisdom it comes
from world vision
people who deal with these issues and
they say why do poor people have large
families
okay let's find out i mean if someone
knows it's got to be world vision right
i mean these people are smart they cover
the planet they help children everywhere
in the world they've got to know why
you know the poor have large families so
what's the reason he said
well they say high child mortality rates
okay so you have too many
kids half of them dies you have more
kids to make up for those that died
great
misconceptions about family planning uh
lack of access to health services okay
what's that got to do with having
children with a sex drive
does that mean if you have access to
health services you're not going to
sleep with a girl next door uh
patriarchal uh values yeah you know uh
in certain cultures you have this
patriarchy model still with
father ordains and that's the model they
copy and they just say well father had
10 children so i'm going to have 10
children too
forced early marriage okay lack of
education
so we have kids because we are ignorant
okay
religious keep all these in mind
religious beliefs
okay yeah god sends me you know the kids
social reputation hey you're the macho
you gotta have ten kids to show that
you're a stud right
family legacy in other words uh you know
it just comes down
the family tree okay and then i had to
expand on this one limited finances what
do they mean families in poverty
farmers for example right may have more
kids
as a way of supporting the family
livelihood okay
and uh part of that is the care for
elders
so this is why poor people have large
family and that's what everybody just
repeats and just
thinks it's uh the truth and they just
repeat it they pair it they say well
it's
common knowledge it's like a no-brainer
is it let's find out if who's the
guy with no brains okay let's uh let's
clarify
these people this is the notion
the notion they have for what uh what
modern day
right poor people look like okay uh
these are
poor families okay and they have lots of
kids so this is the image we have today
we say oh look
all these poor people they're ignorant
they don't have health services they
need to maintain the old
people and so they have kids pure
ignorance and just uh
poor and you know it turns out they're
always uh
dark-skinned they're either black or
indian or mexican yeah it's all those
people who have
all us white folk you know like me hey
we're smart
we stand out of the way of uh you know
i'm white
pale face we have no children even
though you know there's a saying
uh that we have that you know if you
have one child
well that's a modern family if you have
two children whoa that's a
numerous family okay that's a very big
family
and if you have three children
you're a peasant you're a farmer and
i have three boys so you know where i
fit in
i'm a peasant okay so let's clarify to
these people okay what
what where their ignorance lies this is
the filthy rich
of the 19th century these were the
people who had children
okay these were all rich families look
at how many kids they had
do the rich have kids today okay
and then the other issue is look at the
bottom right the bottom right the one in
yellowish color
you know who that fellow is that's jacob
his other name was israel
and he had 12 children the 12 tribes of
israel
why because he was a rich man in his
days that's why they put him in the
bible he was a prominent guy
okay he had cattle
okay so he was prominent he had his
sheep you know he was a
big man he had four wives he had lots of
kids
he was a rich man why those days it was
important for a rich man to have
children
okay so something's changed and now
these people don't have children
okay but you know i have a little uh
anecdote
that i'd like to share and that's that i
had this uh pretty ignorant woman
she was from the country in in another
place another time
okay and uh and she had one
child she came to the city and she had
one child
and i asked her one day i said so when
are you going to have your next one
and she said
what do you mean no and she said no
she's not going to have another one she
can't have another one she can barely
maintain one she had to bring the kid to
work because he was a maid
and here there was this woman she was
not
studied at all she she was not you could
say she's intelligent in the sense that
you know world wise in other words she
she she did understand
and she came to the city she realized
she couldn't have children i said hold
it
let me ask you something how many kids
did your mother have
and she shocked me she her mother had
seven children
that was only her mother because her
father
had a few more he had like five wives in
the town
i mean he was married to one but he he
went around you know and he had like 50
children they all looked like her she
said
so here you had this guy in the country
he's got like five
wives extra official wives he had like
50 children
this woman had seven children here's one
of
her children she comes to the city
and she only has one she doesn't plan to
have any more no matter what
you say hold it this woman is poor
this woman is uneducated
and she does not have children or any
more
children so you say hold it it's got
nothing to do with being poor or being
uneducated it's got to do with something
else
but you know when you drink wine with
water
and you drink you get drunk and when you
drink beer with water you get drunk when
you get
drink rum with water you get drunk
so you conclude that the common factor
is water so water is what's making you
drunk
and that's the era these people are
making they're saying that
poorness is the common factor
and that's not the case not at all
it's coming to the cities it's the
transition
from the country to the cities that's
killing kids
children today the reason we're not
having children is because
women are coming to the men and women
for that matter but primarily women
they're coming to the city and they
realize they can't have children
in the cities that's why we're not
having children
and you know some women take a little
longer than others to realize that some
have two or three by the time they
figure it out that they can't live
in the city with three children and
sometimes it's too late to have to
donate the children here or there you
know foster
homes or leave them at the door of the
church
but it's not really the poor
poor is not the common factor the common
factor is
the fact that we have become urbanized
we've
stopped living in the farms and we're
coming to the cities when you come to
the city you stop having children
and you don't believe me no problem uh
look up the following look of any
country in the world you
your choice any country that you wish
that you choose
okay this is what i'm saying any country
just there's what a hundred and
almost 200 countries in the world look
up the one you want
i want you to find out uh if there's any
country that
um is the the rate
the rate the growth rate of that country
is going down
and just like i uh uh
showed a minute ago you know uh in that
chart
i want you to see if uh not down i mean
going up
you'll see that every country the world
of rain is going down
and the reason is transition what is
transition
the movement from the country to the
city once you come to the city you stop
having children
so the factor of killing children
is the fact that there's this transition
going on when we were in the country
when you have this country mentality
you have children and when you come to
the city you have the city mentality
whether you're in nigeria whether you're
in palestinian whether you're
in china whether you're in south america
it doesn't matter
you come to the city you stop having
children miracle
it's known as density dependent birth
rates
density dependent birth rates what did i
show at the beginning
i showed these fruits
and the bacteria multiply you know
there's this exponential growth
and then they start leveling down and
then when there's no more carrying
capacity
they go down to extinction okay
so what's happening in the world today
total world
is that we stopped having children or
starting to have
to we're stopping
to have children why because we've come
to the cities once we come to the cities
we stop having children
and uh at that point that's when
population stagnates
and because population stagnates there
is no future especially no economic
future
because all businesses rely on demand
what is demand ultimately population
no population no demand and right now
we're headed to
no demand to a flattened out curve that
is going to
peek out it's going to reach some kind
of zenith and then what did we see
the s curve turns into whammo down all
the way to zero
it's got to be very quick also by the
way
okay uh another comment
along the extinction lines as well
extinctions are linked to the sun
cycle poor fellow i mean you know what
does he know
it doesn't do any research all he's
doing is putting off the question
they're saying yeah it's the sun cycle
whatever that is in other words uh
he's avoiding the question he doesn't
want to answer the question and he
doesn't
have an answer for the question i asked
the question was
give me a full proof
full and full proof mechanism for
extinction of man
something man can't do anything about
and of course everybody the only thing
they anybody can think of that man can
do
can't do anything about is the sun they
say well if the sun does something that
goes away
or there's some kind of cycle or
whatever that's the only thing they can
think of in other words they put it off
they say well there's something going on
with the sun
something over there uh that's not an
answer
sorry yeah you got to do a little better
than that a little better research
now uh sun has nothing to do with
extinctions
but that's what these people just repeat
they read it somewhere they get it in
their brains and that's what they
believe
okay uh
here's uh another comment
well says there is no involuntary trade
my god these poor people it must be an
economist
one of these friedman types of romanians
okay let's find out let's find out this
guy uh
is uh has voluntary or involuntary trade
uh
power okay here he is okay okay do you
think
that fellow would um would work for food
or for anything
you know i doubt that fellow has much of
uh chance to
bargain from a position of power of
strength
okay and that's more or less the uh
the situation of lots of people today
we'll we'll call him the
proletariat proletarian okay
and here it is this is uh 19th century
england okay so you can see it here
uh that's how people lived they lived in
the slums they lived in the ghettos
okay you think these people had much of
a choice when they
re made a contract with the person who
hired them
for a factory in the 19th century
what bargaining power did these people
have i mean it's easy to talk when you
have a
filled stomach and also when you have
maybe some
savings or maybe you have something to
trade like i said
when you have only your labor to trade
and there are other competitors around
you
well there's not much bargaining power
on your on your side
so you have to accept whatever is given
to you
i mean it's like the slave the slave
works for food does he have much of a
choice
how about the surf which we covered last
week you know he doesn't have much
in the feudalistic age you know he
doesn't have much of a chance to
bargain and people say well those people
were slaves they were serfs
so what's the difference with the slaves
and serves today that we call
proletarians that work in the offices
i mean what do they work for they
essentially work for food
because uh they're barely above
subsistence level they have very little
disposable income and that means that
essentially all their money goes to
paying for the rent
whatever other things they're paying for
and for food
and that allows them to come to work the
next day because now they're fed
and then then at the end of the month
they get their next check and they can
work another month
and so on down the line and they never
get out of that so yes we'll work for
food and so they don't have much
bargaining power
even much less today and the more we go
on
when everything's by contract so in the
old days it used to be
uh there used to be some unions today
the unions are broken
you know when i were i was a union man i
worked
i was a delegate what was called a
delegate in in argentina
and i worked for the phone company and
um
you know i i went on two strikes we went
through stretch we had to
uh put the pressure on the um
on the powers that be to get them to
bargain with us
but that's gone today i mean today uh
most jobs most industries
out there are non-union and a lot of
people even don't want unions because
they just see them as troublemakers or
causing trouble for them or
you know that they just rather you know
lower their ears and work for whatever
is given to them
and so the worker is going to be losing
real value
the more money that the government
prints
and the more prices rise and the last
thing you rise is always the salary so
the workers little by little are gonna
fall behind until they're
gonna be specifically at the level of
subsistence
uh you know income and when you're at
subsistence
income you have involuntary trade
no no no doubt of my mind at least about
it
you can believe whatever you want okay
another issue
related to squares
probably talk about next time you did it
again you extrapolated a small piece of
my comment
and twisted all its meaning by
distorting and omitting and changing and
mystifying
oh my god i'm so sorry i'm such a
bad guy okay the generic word tree
okay refers to the plant
it's interesting he used the word plant
and not the word object
i wanted to know whether a true the word
tree is
always an object that's what i wanted to
know he didn't use the word object or
thing he said it's a plant aha
so i'm the guy who's being mean and you
know nasty by
you know changing some things the reason
sometimes i leave stuff out is because
these people get tangled in their own
wording and so i have to show them what
they wrote
and so i cut up all the nonsense that's
not relevant and i just say this is what
you said
read what you said this would just say
oh but you left the other stuff i don't
care about the other stuff
it was uh not pertinent
this is what you said this is what you
meant this is what your statement says
and here you see it you say it says
refers to a plant
why did you say the word uh tree refers
to an
object that's the question that was the
question
and he avoided it and so yeah i'm going
to beat him with a baseball bat no no
doubt about it because
this follows a chicken okay he's not
coming he's not coming clean okay and
here it is
okay so here here are the questions for
the saw does the word tree
always refer to an object and i'm
talking about tree and the constant
context of plants okay so
does the word tree always here in the
land of the klingons does the word tree
always refer to an object yes or no it's
a yes or no question
i don't want an explanation i just want
to yes or no to that question
it's a y or an n that's it isn't tree an
object a hundred percent of the times
we use it here and in the land of the
klingons
if not what category of words do you
put it under what do you pretend to put
the word tree under if
it's not an object if it's not a thing
if it's not an
entity a body a structure
i don't know how many more cinnamons i
gotta mention
is the word tree always in reference to
an object
yes or no very simple question i think
and it's a yes or no i don't want
anything after the yes or no i need a
yes or no that's it
does the word tree always always refer
to an object okay and why do i mention
that well because this guy continues and
he says
well let's see um got another issue here
i want to mention before i get to that
one
uh put it over here so this is the issue
okay in science there are only two
categories of words
objects and concepts there is no
third category okay otherwise you're
gonna have to fight very hard because
i'm gonna tear you to pieces if you come
up with a third category that
doesn't fall under one of those two what
is an object that which has shape
okay what is a concept it's a word that
invokes
two objects it's a relation okay
okay that's what it is uh where that
invokes two objects or
two words treated momentarily as objects
for example a
typical case of the word space when we
say space
an object for the word universe the word
space is treated as
if it were an object a thing for the per
moment you know you're talking about two
things a relationship between
the stars the matter and the and the
space
that's what the universe is okay if you
can point to it
okay static single frame independent i'm
not gonna draw all the
little little details everyone who's
been following me knows what i mean by
that i guess
it is an object if i can point to it
it's an object
can i point to a tree hopefully yes
i don't care if the tree is drawn on a
piece of paper
and you say tree i point to it that's
the word tree that's what i'm pointing
to that's a tree it's got shape
okay it's an object
otherwise it is a concept okay so tree
is always an object
don't know how to say it to you but the
word tree
always represents an object so don't
tell me it's a plant
you only alluded to you ran away with it
with your tail between your legs by
saying
oh uh a tree is a plant it's not an
object it's a plant
okay yeah i understand
[Laughter]
okay another issue also with the
tree and i think saint paul says
the representation on the screen
or on a hypothetical sheet is not an
object
and does not exist why does he bring the
word exist into this at all
what does the word exist have to do with
what we're talking about we're talking
about
the definition of the word object we
want to know what an object is
what does he do immediately going to
exist that's what everybody does
it does not exist who cares
we're not talking about existence not
because object didn't exist are
synonymous okay but because i like this
one
2d figures have an uh no location
what do you say he says 2d
figures let me repeat that he said
2d figure that's a 2d figure right a
square is a 2d figure
a circle is a 2d figure i mean we're
just looking at the plane right
here right the face and he's saying
that's not an object
because what 2d figures have no location
that's what he says that's why they're
not synonyms
let's look up the word figure so we
educate this individual
so he kills his ignorance okay
okay let's here it is what is a figure
is that which is contained by any
boundary or boundaries according to mr
euclid what is a figure even if you look
it up in the dictionary today
form or shape so he's saying that to the
object is not an object uh
you just said it's a 2d object it's a
kind of object
it's a 2d object that's what a 2d
figure is it's a 2d object
that's what you said that's why i cut
out all the rubbish that comes after
that because i want to point that out to
you
i don't care what whatever you said
after that doesn't matter
you gotta understand where you get to
the error because you've got a mental
problem in not understanding what i'm
saying
i'm saying that if you're gonna use the
word figure and you're gonna call it a
2d
figure you're saying 2d object and
that's what a square is it's a 2d
object we can get rid of the 2d because
we don't need it because it's an object
is it just a different type of object
than a cube
or or you know a tree or a dog
these are different kinds of objects but
they're all
objects why are they objects that's what
you got to figure out
is it not an object because it's 2d well
you just said it's a 2d
object so it is an object according to
you
i don't know if i'm making getting
through to you but you just said it's a
2d figure and a figure is an object
and you're saying that it's not an
object
so you figure it out you you got to look
at the mirror and look at your soul
in there okay i can't help you any
further okay
it's all these people who they're all
these people have
one uh thing in mind and keep this
very tightly with you okay what do they
have in mind they're protecting their
religion these people
want to protect their words they want to
protect the ether the field
the plasma these words that they use
they want to
defend the wave time uh
you know all these words that they use
as physical objects
and what do i say that the definition of
the word object
destroys all religions they want to
protect their religion they say no
you're not going to destroy my religion
because i've been doing this for 20 30
years
and you're telling me now that my
religion is worthless
because you define the word object
differently
well you got to get in the ring and
fight for the word object you got to
tell me what an object is because
physics cannot be done without an object
and physics deals with which objects
with those that exist
physics doesn't deal with objects that
don't exist like circles
okay and again we're not talking about
this okay in a sense we're talking about
the face
of this that's what a circle is the
circle is not three-dimensional circle
is two-dimensional okay it's got only
length uh width and height that's all uh
a
circle has but but the point here is
that
uh you know a circle is an object and so
are anything that is two-dimensional
it's it's an object it's just a
two-dimensional
what object two-dimensional what figure
that's the word you're gonna use
otherwise what are you gonna call it
a two-dimensional what concept
do concepts have dimensions width and
height
okay so yeah you got to look uh deep
into your soul here okay
you got to get your language straight
i'm going to be tough on you
i'm going to use my uh dough roller on
you
okay be ready bill's coming after you
okay final issue today question comment
here
fella says i do not understand why you
say that the
torsion is not instantaneous he's
talking about the uh
rope okay and remember
the rope model of light what are we
talking about well we're talking about
torsion moving along the rope okay
that's what we're talking about
so phil says uh i do not understand why
you say that the torsion is not
instantaneous zero time
okay notice what he's saying zero time
never heard of that but what is zero
time
you know i know about one second time
two second time
minute time hour time year time i know
all those
i've never heard of zero time zero time
sounds like no time at all
and it's like multiplying one second
times zero what do you get well you get
zero seconds
what is zero seconds is that zero time
one frame in the in the universal movie
is that what zero time is just one frame
you mean location is that what
uh zero time means zero
zero motion uh is that location
the hypothesis of rope is that
is rigid and right meaning straight i
guess you meant by that
if the rope is not rigid okay
the oscillation of the atom jump is
equal to
c okay he's saying that the pumping
right of the atom has to be at a
velocity or speed
of of little c 300 000 kilometers per
second
to torque the rope at that speed
okay to match the speed of light okay
and deformation of the rope need to be
considered
oh man here's here's the experiment i
can
tell you to do to convince yourself that
that's nonsense
okay take a rope okay two
two strand rope okay steal it from your
grandmother
okay tie it at one end okay you died at
one end okay
and then i want you to do the following
stand up one corner
with the two strands in your hand one in
each hand
and i want you to open them as quickly
as you possibly can right
hopefully you don't do it at the speed
of light
okay and it'd be nice if you film that
or have someone film it from the side
okay
so you opened up the rope and you open
up in i don't know
even if you want to do it slowly you can
do it slowly okay
and the question is whether the speed
of the torsion along the rope
in other words if you time it
right if you look at the speed from the
point of
origin of the disturbance to where it
reaches
if that distance is the same as the
distance between your two hands
okay so you open up the two strands this
thing rolls
all the way down yeah to some place that
you can film
and this again a very coarse experiment
crude one
right that's the best i can offer you
but obviously if you do this in a more
controlled scenario you would probably
reach a much
better a more precise uh
conclusion and that's that when you pull
this the distance the speed of this
is not the same speed as the one along
the rope
the one along the road we call c little
c that's the
three hundred thousand kilometers per
second which is the speed of light
this pole is not three hundred thousand
kilometers per second
and neither is the pumping of those two
atoms
okay so the speed along the the rope
is of the signal along the rope is much
faster than the
pumping of the two atoms in fact it's uh
i think it's more or less like a 10 to
1 ratio and that's because they measured
the
speed of the electricity maybe that's a
rule of thumb but again all these things
are very up in here they don't really
have speeds for any of these things yet
not not very strong strong ones uh
ask a mechanic quantum mechanic if the
speed of pumping of the back and forth
going
of the little bead uh electron bead that
the quantum jumps from energy level to
energy level if that travels at the
speed of light
ask them that question and see if
they'll give you they'll tell you that
an electron falls at the speed of light
because if it does it turns into energy
according to good old einstein
so uh keep that in mind okay and here's
the real reason okay
mona lisa cannot smile instantly we
don't know anything
any any uh motion that is instant
instant refers to location okay
and motion and time uh
involves several frames at least two
frames of the universal
movie okay so mona lisa cannot smile
in a single frame that's not a smile in
order for her to smile she's got to move
her lips at least a little bit
she's got to move her face somehow
otherwise it's not the verb
to smile okay and people confuse
ordinary speech with scientific language
smile
for the purposes of scientific language
is a verb
verb requires two frames as a minimum of
the universal movie
okay so we can't have a smile in a
single frame you cannot have
instant motion instant time
zero time whenever you talk about zero
time whenever you talk about
instant motion what you're talking about
is location
of static concept
and hopefully that sank into some brains
out there
and with that i'll see you next time
which is on sunday
and i'll probably do a little more
geometry because
people have a tough time understanding
uh all the errors we've made for 2000
years with
geometry and i got to clarify it for
them
i got to show them where the errors are
and they don't have to believe me again
it's to get them to think
okay we've done a mess